what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down just how strong series
antagonist tomara shigaraki is from the
my hero Academia Series shigaraki has
certainly become one of the most
powerful anime villains we've had over
the years not only powerful but super
fascinating too so today we will be
breaking down shigaraki's power by
looking into his quirks abilities fights
and more so make sure you stay tuned for
this one we have made loads of my hero
Academia videos over here on the channel
now from like analytical videos to
chapter reviews as they drop if you do
enjoy this video then make sure to check
out our last my hero video like this
where we look into every one for all
User it's a tasty one and I'm sure
you'll love it so make sure to check
that video out after this one link to
that is in the video description now if
you do enjoy these my hero Academia
videos on the channel and you'd like to
see more you know what to do so smash
that like button it really does help us
out a lot if you haven't already make
this the video you subscribe and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications you can also follow us on
Twitter and Instagram at animeopro and
now without further Ado let's jump into
It spoilers and all tomorrow shigaraki
born on April 4th is 20 years old when
we are first introduced to him in the
series which was in chapter 11 of the
mha manga and episode 8 of the anime now
he is currently 21 years old at the time
of this video's making he stands at 175
centimeters which is about 5 foot 9
inches and weighs 131 pounds his real
name was of course that of tenko shimura
grandson of the previous one for all
user Nana shimaran who was the seventh
user of The Quirk and former mentor of
the former number one hero all mind now
for me one of the most fascinating
things about shigaraki comes in his
growth I'm not sure if I'm alone in
thinking this but when we were first
introduced to him as the big bad of the
series you know the one who would stand
before series protagonist izuku midoriya
as his greatest enemy I was a little
underwhelmed by him he seemed more like
that of a bratty young man who had a
chip on his shoulder the you know the
world must pay for things seemingly
didn't go his way and it was the world
who was at fault for this yes he had the
Warped personality and darker side to
him that he'd expect to see in a villain
one where he could easily carry out
malicious intent including murder on
others without you know battering an eye
of its evil Deeds but he just seemed to
be an angry man-child who would
constantly strop when things didn't go
his way I personally struggled to see
how I could see him as the big finale to
the series you know yes he had some
moments where he installed Terror in us
such as the meeting with Deku at the
kiyashi ward shopping mall and the final
exams Arc you know it was the way he
menacingly had his hand around deku's
throat threatening to use his Quirk
Decay on him if he were to Simply place
his last finger around his neck it was
definitely a moment where I thought okay
yes this guy certainly has something
about him but prior to that and slightly
after I I was largely unimpressed by him
now my point with all of this is that I
can strongly stand here now and tell you
that I was 100 wrong about this man it
was in his growth and you know the
overall puzzle that is Toma shigaraki
that makes him a terrifying villain as
each of these puzzle pieces come
together throughout the series we are
also following the Journey of how this
all-powerful villain came to be and
that's for me what makes shigaraki such
a powerful character in this series and
now the villain you look at as the real
big bad of the show with all the respect
that he deserves just as we have been
watching midori's story throughout mha
of how he became the greatest hero
parallel to this we've also been
watching shigaraki's story of how he
became the greatest villain and man I
can't get over just how well this has
been executed so yeah throughout the
video we will be talking about
shigaraki's power his quirks and what
makes him so strong but I think you know
that growth or Journey you know the path
the man has taken also leads to his
overall strength now in terms of his
natural abilities shigaraki pre-awful
one was a lot more stronger than his
appearance led us to believe as the
leader of the league of villains he was
able to deploy his units to the
carefully planned and strategic manner
of his well thought out plans during the
usj incident we saw shigaraki take on a
razor head now there are two things that
we can take from this you know the first
is that shigaraki seemingly has no fear
and the confidence in his own abilities
to take on a Pro Hero all by himself and
he was definitely stronger than we
thought he would be as he was able to
pretty much go toe-to-toe with him even
causing damage to isawa's right arm
using his Decay Quirk shigaraki was even
confident enough to take on four UA
students at once that being izuki
midoriya kotsuki bakugou Shoto Todoroki
and ezrao kiroshima yes this four were
nothing compared had to how they were
you know now but each of these students
still showcased that they had that
potential within them the meeting with
these four also showcased to us that
shigaraki was also a very tough
character when it came to his own
durability now he took one of bakugou's
explosions head on and took little
damage at all showing that this man was
going to be a very hard foe to take down
Not only was shigaraki you know strong
physically and able to take some pretty
big hits he also demonstrated great
speeds in his own movements with his
Quirk being one that would only work
when he physically touches something
shigaraki needed to move at very high
speeds to be able to get himself into
the prime location where he is in a
position to you know Dodge incoming
attacks catch his Target by surprise and
then land the all-important contact for
his Quirk to completely devastate them
and looking back at the events of the
usj arc I do think I was maybe being a
little harsh on shigaraki and how I
didn't look at him as a proper end
villain but I guess that's hindsight
with what we know now I think the main
thing that did stand out to me at the
time and you know in his praise was that
of the man's intellect you could
definitely see that he had a very sharp
eye for detail and just a sharp a mind
to be able to react to those details
that he was taking in shigaraki quickly
manages to work out how his opponents
quirks and fighting styles work by
simply observing them while they are in
practice he will then deduce how he can
make their strengths work in his
Advantage we saw this in his battle
against isawa where he quickly worked
out his Quirk a razor and its weaknesses
so that he could not only counter it but
then turn the situation so it posed
strongly in his own favor you really
can't fault the man in this field and he
is certainly a person who seems easy to
work out and understand but in reality
you just have no idea what this guy is
up to shigaraki is all about the
unexpected and this is without a doubt
one of his greatest strength lengths
especially in those very early stages of
the mha story so this leads us to a very
good point to talk about his Quirk you
know we have briefly mentioned it
already in the video but let's break it
down more here so shigaraki's Quirk is
called Decay which one is a very
devastating ability and two are very
very awesome name for a villain's Quirk
so big props to our boy horikoshi on
that one so back in the day shigaraki's
Decay Quirk would allow him to
disintegrate anything that he touches
with all five of his fingers or you know
all four of his fingers in one thumb for
the technicals out there this
disintegration worked at very high and
Rapid speeds upon Chicago's contacts
spreading through their entire bodies in
a mere instant now this can be stopped
if a person is able to amputate the
decaying part of their body so yes there
is a way in which to stop this but what
a devastating way to have to stop it it
really is Advantage shigaraki when his
Decay Quirk comes play now his Decay
Quark also works on non-living beings
too such as building structures and so
on shigaraki's decay can also spread
beyond that of what he is touching which
in turn allows him to take out a group
of enemies all at once the Decay Quirk
is a very very nasty one to come up
against but like all quirks it does have
its weaknesses the first is to of course
prevent you know him from touching you
since he needs to be able to physically
touch whatever it is he chooses to Decay
you know what he is up to and in such
you know there will be a moment in which
he comes to you and even for a split
second shigaraki will be open and
vulnerable to attack himself the other
weakness would be if he were to come up
against those whose quirks allowed them
to turn their own bodies into a
non-solid object such as you know either
water or sand as we of course know Decay
would later go on to awaken and become a
lot more devastating but for now we
shall move forward so shigaraki has
always had a very distinctive look about
him and you know that was in his
costumes when which were a set of 14
disembodied hands these hands covered
his head and upper body so when I
mentioned that shigaraki was like a
puzzle and you know which we were fed
pieces of him throughout the story that
not only led to his growth but also to
who he was as a villain these hands were
of course a major factor here so these
hands were all in fact near the hands of
his family that shigaraki had
accidentally killed when his Decay Quirk
activated for the first time every top
villain needs that killer backstory and
shigaraki is certainly no exception so
formerly tenko shimura born to both now
and kotara shimra lived in a house built
by his father with his older sister
Hannah and his maternal grandparents
tenko did not seem to have a quirk of
his own but instead he had an unknown
allergy that frequently caused him to
scratch his own face tenko was five
years old at the time and he had a love
and Fascination for Heroes like most of
the other kids his age his father
however hated everything to do with
Heroes and was very strict in his ways
of scolding the poor young tenko if he
were to ever bring them up his father
you know was a very horrible man in this
regard but of course he had his own
reasonings his mother was the seventh
one for all user Nana shimra who had to
abandon him for his own safety of course
you know he was never properly told that
so you can understand the grudge this
was also never explained to tenko who
would also be on the receiving end of
his father's anger when The Mention Of
Heroes arose the rest of the family
would their comfort tanko but none of
them dared to stand up to his father
tenko caused trouble one day when he was
pretending to be a hero and his father
punished him by leaving tenko outside
with no food until he had apologized the
rest of the family tried to tell kotaro
that he was being too harsh but yeah he
wouldn't listen tanko's mother notices
that his allergies are getting worse but
his father mentions that he hasn't
manifested a quirk yet if it's because
of the allergies then his suffering now
will prevent any future suffering he may
get in his road to becoming a hero this
was also confusing for the young tanko
and to No Surprise of course he was only
five years old and this kid didn't know
if his own father hates him because you
know of his love for Heroes it was a
really sad time for tenko and in an
attempt to cheer him up his sister
Hannah took him to his father's office
and showed him a photo of his father as
a child with his mother who was clearly
none other than a hero herself Hannah
told tenko the truth about his
grandmother and this understandably made
tanko so very very happy Hannah wanted
to support her brother's dream of one
day becoming a hero and admitted that
she shared that same dream too of course
this is where things took a very very
very dark tan tenko was playing outside
with the family dog yeah he was
extremely happy to have found out that
there was a hero in his family and then
felt a very strange and uncomfortable
feeling in his hand as he looked down he
realized that part of the ball that he
was holding had started to crumble away
at the same moment tenko's father found
out about the pair breaking into his
office and looking at the photograph of
his hero mother he was absolutely
Furious and went off on a wild rage he
demanded that he was told who was
responsible to which his sister broke
down in Fry and and panic said that it
was all tenko's idea to which of course
it obviously wasn't kotaro went into a
furious rage and started beating the
poor tenko whose allergies began to
worsen with every passing second tenko
was itching relentlessly at this point
and he was begging his family for help
all they could do was just look on in
horror of the situation after the
beating he was again punished to stay
outside tenko was sobbing uncontrollably
as much as he was scratching at himself
he hugged the family dog for comfort and
said that he couldn't take this abuse
anymore and that he hated his family for
leaving him to suffer at the hands of
his father as tenko clutch tied her to
his dog his Decay Quirk finally began to
activate causing the dog to crumble in
his very arms tenko understandably began
to freak out at what had just happened
you know his dog had just died something
weird had happened to his own body and
he was responsible for the death of said
dog I honestly can't even begin to
imagine those feelings rushing through
his head it must have been insane
at this very moment his sister Hannah
came outside to apologize to him tenko
desperately tried to stop her and warn
her not to come any closer but the shock
caused him to not you know be able to
speak himself Hannah noticed what had
happened and she then freaked out in
horror tenko desperately tried and
pleaded for his sister's help but as he
touched at his decade Quirk instantly
disintegrated her realizing what he had
just done the further trauma caused
tenko to vomit next his grandparents
came outside and tenko's mind was all
over the place he hated them for leaving
him to be beated by his father but he
was traumatized and scared by what was
going on that you know his hatred forced
him to make the ground and his
grandparents crumble before him his
mother tried desperately to help her son
but her body crumbled away just before
she could reach out to him now finally
his father kotra was alerted to the
noise and went outside himself
completely horrified by what he saw he
could only stand and stare as a
distraught tenko pleaded for his help of
course continuing to be father of the
year kotaro instead pulled out a pair of
gardening shares to protect himself and
slashed at tenko cutting his son's face
and this was the moment tenko's rage and
hatred fully consumed him in this moment
and he lunged at his father he grabbed
hold of his father's face with furious
intent to kill in this scene we yeah we
saw just how much pain Agony and you at
the same time ecstasy the young tenko
was feeling in this moment which
resulted in the entire house crumbling
as well of course this event led to
tenko becoming an orphan on the streets
no one wanted anything to do with him
because of his scary appearance until he
was eventually taken in by all for one
who adopted him as if he was his own son
well he told tenko he was going to take
him home and that from now on he would
be his master but you know we all know
that this was the start of all for one
grooming the young tenko as his adoptive
son
so he was taken in given a room of his
own and was gifted the hands of his
deceased family members understandably
this caused tenko to go into shock ujiko
asked if he should modify tenko but all
for one refused saying that his hatred
will linger within tenko teaching him
purpose tengo embraced his family's
remains and all for one told him that he
had an Impulse to destroy that couldn't
be controlled this urges couldn't be
satisfied which led to the Relentless
itching that he felt he said that this
need to destroy didn't have to be
controlled nor was it a bad thing
tanko later ran into two thugs in an
Alleyway who beat him up he wanted to
use his the cake work on them but he
backed down in this moment tenko then
went back to his room in shame and
itched violently because of the incident
all for one comforted him and asked
tenko what he wanted to do in that
moment then tenko looked at the hands of
his family and declared that he wanted
to kill the two thugs his rage towards
the two who hit him caused him to pick
up and Decay one of the hands this of
course pleased all for one greatly and
he knew what needed to be done so tenko
returned to the two thugs but this time
was wearing his family's hands he was
told that if he were to wear these hands
then his family would always be with him
Dark Twisted and all sorts of wrong the
dogs of course called him creepy but
tenko quickly dispatched of them using
his Decay Quirk this was a weird one
because tenko felt sick and disgusted
with himself but at the same time he
felt a sense of complete calm he felt
that at this moment he could do anything
that he so wished all for one anujiko
watched from a nearby rooftop with great
pride now back at home all for one
congratulated tenko and gifted him with
five more hands so that he would always
remember this day four of the hands were
of the two thugs he had just murdered
and the fifth was a small bonus for the
one he had destroyed earlier that day
putting on the new Hands All For One
gifted tenko a new name tomurite
shigaraki tomorrow comes from the word
that means to mourn and shigaraki is the
real last name of all for one after
these events All For One race shigaraki
to eventually become his successor in
the league of villains and met the
nomukurugiri who was tasked with aiding
and with the development of shigaraki
himself so yeah pretty gnarly backstory
there and one that propels shigaraki as
the main villain of the series
backstories can really make or break a
character but shigarakis was very you
know dark and opened up so much more on
his character so before we move on let's
just look at the hands that shigaraki
wears so the two around his neck are
that of his mother's the ones on his
upper arms and elbows are that of his
maternal grandparents his sister hands
are worn around his wrists now the hands
on his shoulders and mid section are
those hands of the two thugs and the
hand that he wears over his face is that
of his father's there is one more hand
that he wears on the back of his head
this was the one that was gifted to him
as a replacement for the other hand of
his fathers that he decayed now this is
later revealed to be the hand of none
other than his paternal grandmother Nana
shimura so because of his past trauma
and you know his extreme hate for the
hero Society shigaraki has developed an
incredibly strong display of willpower
this willpower of his is argument really
one of tomara shigaraki's greatest
strengths and one that has been shown to
strike the essence of complete fear in
his enemies shigaraki has often been on
the losing end of a battle but through
his sheer determination to never give in
to not be defeated until he has reached
his goal and to continue to itch the
urge to destroy absolutely everything he
has always found a way to come out on
top shikaraki just has this very intense
and very frightening aura about him that
is very clear to see his Gaze fixated on
his one and only target as one of pure
malice and these two things are fueled
by this willpower of his now his will
I've always likened to you know the Sith
in Star Wars who draw upon their hatred
to give them more power the stronger
their feelings of hate the more power
and you know more devastating they
become even managing to pull off things
that are considered impossible
shigaraki's hatred you know his will to
destroy is what makes him so powerful as
a villain without his hatred to pull
upon shigaraki would have been defeated
deleted a long time ago but he always
gets right back up no matter you know
the opponent or how strong the attacks
they have his will allows him to shrug
off injuries or pain that would KO a
normal opponent and the scary thing
about it is that shigaraki will get back
up even stronger than before now it was
also shigaraki's will that was one of
the key reasons that all for one chose
tomora as his successor it was
shigaraki's Will to Destroyer that would
force the current one for all user as
well as the spirits of the previous
users out to confront him so that they
could make one for all's power one of
their own and that shigaraki's body and
will were more than strong enough to
steal that power when the time would
come we of course see shigaraki
continuing to grow as the series
progressed but not in any major way
after the downfall of all for one at the
hands of all my overhaul visited the
league of villains Hideout but is not
impressed by The Hideout or by shigaraki
himself for that matter with all for
one's defeat the Throne of the
underworld was very bacon and awaiting a
new king shigaraki of course believes
this spot to be his but doesn't have a
plan in getting there which leaves
overhaul disappointed going as far as
saying that the league of villains
should join under him this of course was
a strong no from shigaraki but as this
Arc played out you could see that the
two groups were kind of forming some
sort of Alliance though neither side
truly trusted the other it always seemed
that one side was waiting for the other
to slip up and this for me was more
growth for shigaraki but more mental
growth than that physical shigaraki was
playing the long game here and more than
that we got to see just how sadistic he
could be so overhaul eventually fell to
the heroes and was captured the league
of villains located the transport that
was carrying over hauler managed to
capture it shigaraki frees overhaul from
the police van but he is still
restrained here shikaraki mocks over
whole phrase arrogance and his ultimate
failure while shigaraki is explaining
that he hates him overhaul believes that
shigaraki is going to kill him here but
what shigaraki does next is much more
brutal overhaul's Quirk gives him the
ability to disassemble anything that he
touches and he can then reassemble that
thing however he pleases overhaul's main
plan of course was to take other
people's quirks away from them so that
he and his group had the sole power so
the shigaraki instead of killing
overhaul there and then what shikaraki
does is to take his Quirk away from him
by removing his arms Mr compress gets
payback and removes overhaul's left arm
with his Quirk while shigaraki uses
Decay on his right arm as it begins to
Decay shigaraki amputates overhaul's
right arms so that the Decay doesn't
spread throughout his entire body
leaving him alive now unable to ever
activate his Quirk again shigaraki
taunts him for being a helpless
quirkless man he gloats by saying
everything you've worked so hard for is
mine now he continues to laugh in his
face knowing that the league of villains
will be the rulers of the underworld and
not him all the while overhaul will be
alive and Powerless to do anything about
it other than watch in this
truly horrifying moment all overhaul can
do here is scream in a combination of
you know sheer horror and frustration I
have to say this was honestly one of the
first times I was truly shocked and
scared of tomra shigaraki this was a
huge moment the you know cemented him as
the vision of absolute pure evil so
shigaraki's Powers continued to grow
naturally over time not just his Quirk
but all of his natural abilities with it
this was on full display when he was
tasked with taming and making giganto
machia obey him the league of villains
were incredibly weak broke and without
much of a plan at this time with you
know even the members questioning
shigaraki's ability to lead them Dr
eujiko had offered chigaraki a way out
but only if he could prove himself
against his master's old bodyguard this
was a very long and drawn out battle
that lasted over a month and a half but
absolutely everything shigaraki had at
this point was seen to have developed
and were definitely continuing to grow
throughout the
shigaraki was very close to taming
giganto machia as they were then
contacted by reedestro the grand
commander of the meta Liberation Army
who had captured jiren and were holding
him hostage forcing the league of
villains to face off against the meta
Liberation Army in dike City this Arc my
villain Academia was a very very strong
one for shigaraki as we got a visual
display of just how much stronger he and
the league had become although they were
all of course beginning to fatigue due
to the month and a half battle with
giganto machia so it was in his battle
against red Destro that we saw shigaraki
undergo a quirk Awakening this Quirk
Reawakening significantly boosted the
power Effectiveness and reach of
shigaraki's decay in the battle
shigaraki lost three of his fingers but
he could still use Decay though it was
much weaker and less effective however
with the Quirk Awakening shigaraki could
completely demolish anything his power
comes into contact with even if he
hadn't made contact with
self physically shigaraki demonstrated
the awesome power of His awakened Decay
by completely destroying daika City and
handing reedestro a massive l in their
battle together by using his one good
hand later he underwent surgery on his
hand which significantly boosted the
power of His decade work as we saw when
he took out almost a third of jakku City
using Decay even being hit by the rubble
affected by his Quirk was strong enough
to kill the unfortunate person who came
into contact with it not only did the
cave become much stronger but shigaraki
also gained a lot more control over the
Quirk too allowing him to hit specific
targets at will and spare those that he
wanted to while devastating everything
around him now the conclusion of
shigaraki and redastro's fight results
in a union between the meta Liberation
Army and the league of villains now
named the Paranormal Liberation Front
who is led by none other than shigaraki
himself who also has the respect of
giganto machia at this point so
shigaraki then undergoes surgery to make
him even more powerful than he has
already become the result of this
surgery will be to obtain a body that
has much greater control a body that
will be able to wield a power much
greater than all for one himself this
new body will even allow shigaraki to
obtain one for all which interestingly
was a quirk shigaraki didn't know about
until it was explained to him before the
surgery now of course the downside to
this surgery is that it will last for
four months not only will it take that
long but shigaraki will also have to
endure an Agony greater than anything he
ever has felt before as we know
shigaraki didn't manage to finish the
surgery as at 75 completion his tank is
completely destroyed by miracle and the
doctors equipment by present Mike during
the hero's raid on the Paranormal
Liberation Front Hideout however even at
75 completion shigaraki is a completely
different Beast now so much so that
endeavor compared him to all my in terms
of raw physical power hour and all the
pro Heroes could instantly sense that
shigaraki needed to be taken down and
quickly so in terms of his natural
abilities here shigaraki's strength was
augmented greatly we saw just how high
he could jump and how mobile he was by
just using the muscles of his suit or
body I mentioned Endeavor had compared
him to all might in this field but the
doctor said that he wasn't quiet at his
level just yet however we did see just
how strong he was when he was taking on
Endeavor ryukyu and Deku using one for
all at 45 shigaraki also managed to
overpower them with relative ease all
while izawa was erasing his quirks Not
only was he a beast physically but his
speed stamina and durability were all
skyrocketed by the surgery shigaraki was
able to blast around jakku City out
maneuvering several Pro Heroes and by
pushing his body Beyond his current
limit he was even able to catch up to
Gran Torino who is the fastest hero in
the world the amount of insane power
moves his body was able to with and was
also nothing short of insane as we know
Endeavor has zero chill when it comes to
his moves and fighting style yet
shigaraki was able to brush off a hell's
curtain and move on with things even
bakugo's AP machine gun was nothing to
shigaraki and to further demonstrate his
sheer insane durability was shigaraki
withstanding multiple Deku 100 one for
all smashes to go with this durability
is the ability to withstand the huge
amount of pain he would have endured
from these attacks and to still keep
fighting you know to push himself
further Beyond his limits moving faster
and hitting harder than he had before
despite these impressive Feats his body
did of course have its limits though he
had pushed Beyond them and he showed
moments of temporarily beginning to
break down he'd eventually lose
Consciousness in this fight but only to
regain his Consciousness and keep
fighting though it wasn't shigaraki who
regained Consciousness here but all for
one who was in control of shikaraki's
body all for one confirmed that
shigaraki had taken a loss to daku and
Endeavor in this fight but she igoraki
must face this loss for his own sake he
does manage to escape the battlefield so
that he can finish off his surgery and
come back to fight again at 100 now part
of shigaraki's surgery was having all
for one's original Quirk transplanted to
him the awful one Quirk allows its user
to steal the quirks of other people and
use them as if those quirks were you
know their own creating an arsenal of
superpowers at their disposal so let's
look at the quirks that shigaraki has or
has had the first is of course super
regeneration in which shigaraki can
regenerate and heal himself from any
wound or injury that he had suffered at
very high rates shigaraki really takes
high speed regeneration to a brand new
level not only in its speed but in the
injuries he has suffered and recovered
from such as a mighty hell flame from
Endeavor back in chapter 274. he had air
cannon in which he could shoot out
powerful blasts of air from the palms of
his hands to also increase the amount of
damage he can dish out with his attacks
he also had the Quirk heavy payload as
as well as that he could manipulate his
own muscles to improve his own physical
strength and speed called spring-like
limbs rivet stab is a quirk in which
shigaraki can create large black
tendrils with red cracks in them that he
can use on the offensive to pierce his
enemies he also had scatter which
allowed shigaraki to split up
projectiles coming at him that would
then scatter all over the air now to
increase his evasive abilities he has
The Quirk Wing which as the name
suggests allows shikaraki to grow two
huge black wings from his back gifting
him the ability of flight radio waves is
a quirk that allows shigeraki to disrupt
radio waves which will cause his
opponent's Communications to completely
malfunction which severely dense their
strategy moving forward shigaraki of
course also has the search Quirk that
was formerly ragdolls this Quirk allows
him to look at about 100 different
people at a time determining their
location and even their weaknesses
allowing shigaraki to completely
overwhelm them or launch stealth-like
attacks shigaraki also had the reflect
Quirk where he could reflect attacks
back at his opponents but this Quirk was
eventually destroyed by star and Stripes
New Order Quirk speaking of we actually
saw shigaraki used the stealing powers
of all for one in that battle against
America's number one pro hero star and
strive stealing her Quirk which we had
just mentioned New Order he used the
power of the one for all Quirk to steal
new order from star and stripe this
Quirk allowed shigaraki to create and
set up two rules on his surroundings
that would then be manipulated in his
will however due to a rule in which she
had already set in place before it was
stolen The Quirk revolted against the
other Quirk shigaraki had in his body
this then caused The Quirk to
self-destruct and take out some of the
quirks he had stored up already now
shigaraki's battle against her was an
absolutely thrilling and important
battle for him we really got to see just
what shigaraki was made of here and just
how terrifying a man he had com mad
props to his durability as well by the
way that was clearly shown in this
battle star and stripe used An Almighty
Hypersonic InterContinental Cruise punch
an attack so ferocious that it could
actually be seen from the Japanese
Mainland shigaraki managed to bury
himself underground to protect himself
from the main brunt of the attack but
even still most of his body was
completely destroyed from the blast
shigaraki however managed to continue
fighting and eventually get the win now
going back to the All For One Quirk just
as one for all the Quirk contains the
will and consciousness of its previous
owners now whereas the previous one for
all users are on deku's side helping him
to grow strong enough to defeat the big
bad all for one's previous owner is of
course not that good a guy instead all
for one is trying to take control of
shigaraki's body through shigaraki's
negative and hateful emotions I tend to
like an all-for-one as a virus on
shigaraki and for me the inner struggle
he had with this power again added more
love for shigaraki as the big part of
mha so lastly we have to talk about the
current Final War Arc and of course
those monstrous forms that shigaraki has
undergone now due to the surgery which
modified shigaraki's body and gave him
all for one and the many other quirks
chigaraki's body continues to grow at an
alarmingly high rate this accelerated
growth has caused shigaraki's body to
mutate so that it could adapt to the
quirks and powers that he possessed this
is also known as Quirk Singularity now
these mutated forms of shigarakis are
really something else the missing
fingers on his left hand began to slowly
regrow until the process greatly
accelerates where shigaraki's left arm
becomes this monstrous and grotesque arm
of moving fingers in different shapes
and sizes the result of its gross look
is that shigaraki's decay is a lot more
devastating and not only its reach but
its power too shigaraki said himself
that this was his body adapting to the
large amount of quirks that have been
stockpiled within him that are
frantically searching for its final and
most perfect form the final form is
something we have seen very recently in
the mha manga at the time of this video
making which is his Apex form this thing
looks insane and like the word of the
moment here monstrous his torso and head
are entirely covered in hands and his
own left hand has the images of the
shimura family now of course we haven't
seen the true power of this form yet due
to monama using isawa's Erasure on him
but I feel that it will only be a matter
of time before shigaraki is released
from that especially as this is set up
to be the big final battle between
himself and daku all for one versus one
for all and you know I can't wait to see
just how powerful and epic this final
form is going to be so that is it for
shigaraki truly a progression story with
an mha into the overwhelming and chaotic
villain he has become now he is easily
the strongest villain in all of the mha
story and I really really can't wait to
see this guy go all out though I will of
course be rooting for our boy Deku
Obviously good luck to him good luck to
him is all I'm saying so I hope you
enjoyed today's video highlighting
shigaraki as a villain as well as his
powers and abilities let us know in the
comment section below what your thoughts
on tomorrow shigaraki are and if you
have any interesting theories on him as
we move into mha's Final Phase how
strong do you think he is going to be of
course if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more mha videos on the
channel make sure to let us know by
Smashing that like button if you haven't
already make this the video you
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future mha videos including weekly
chapter reviews as they come out
remember you can also follow us on
Twitter and Instagram at anime or prom
thanks again we can't wait to see you in
the next video till then my friends take
care of yourselves